um okay we're about to go live
okay okay you guys guys guys guys what
up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today is the
first episode of the pregame
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell als if you have any
questions for the stream
oh wait where did she go if you have any
oh no you're good there's alcohol over
there if you have any questions
oh okay
if there are any questions for the
stream super chat them and we will be
reading them in front of the panel
okay
let me pull up
okay so everyone
oh no
[Music]
anyway so um today we are going to start
with our names ages where you're from
and have you ever been in a toxic
relationship
okay so my name is pearl i am 25 i'm
from chicago
what you have to answer the question yes
i said yeah
damn yeah
go ahead
um i'm jessica i'm 23 and i'm from new
jersey and i've been in several so
i'm gabby i'm 22 i'm from sacramento
california
sacramento california and i have also
been in several
going both ways sometimes i'm toxic so
it's good to be self-aware
that's the first step right acceptance
i'm abby i'm 24 and i've been in one
toxic relationship
i feel better now
um i'm jessica i'm from california and
i've been in
a few toxic relationships
okay
so do you think like women always say
they don't want toxic men but is there
something about us that maybe we like
the
games personally i don't like the games
i don't like these yeah i do i feel like
there's a lot of like um childish stuff
that goes with toxicity
which i don't like okay i think it
depends on so i don't think you like the
toxicity i think you like the person or
maybe you do like the toxicity because
you like that person like it's a part of
them mm-hmm but i just feel like you're
more attractive person so you take that
mm-hmm you know how that is better for
worse yeah you kind of take that from
them
i get what you're saying but for better
for words
as soon as you show me worse i'm out
i feel like you know we can do better
for ourselves
it depends on how much you want for
yourself like if you say do you know
what i want better i have this standard
up here like for me right now i'm like
i'm there's a standard i want there's
like a level of
commitment
and
um
generosity and attitude and behavior i
want from a person
so it's like i hold that so sacred i
feel like it depends on how you hold
yourself
so you can say no
depending on like even if you really
love that person it's like you want
yourself more i think it's also the fact
that you would expect the best out of
your partner like you see them in such a
highlight that you don't expect them to
treat you poorly until it happens and
you're like well they've never done this
before so they won't do it again yeah so
again and you're like
what's going on here and can't you keep
letting them do it and you're like damn
okay how are you going to change are you
going to do something different but it's
getting rough but i love them so much
because we stuck through all of this
garbage when we don't need to
so that's why love is blind
don't get me started about that wait so
so question
when how long were you in the
relationship before you realized it was
toxic because for me it didn't start out
that way did it start out that way for
you guys
[Music]
an act i feel like or maybe they have
this
um ideology they want to be
and i think that's what it was in my
scenario they had this ideology of who
they want to be and they acted like that
i believed it
more for me
and
i believed it and then obviously you get
when you get deep into a relationship
you even when you're around that person
a lot you get to see a lot of their
traits good or bad
um you get to see a lot of their
behavior their attitudes how they react
to situations how they handle situations
like when you have an argument which is
okay in a relationship
arguments are toxic i think it's just
how you handle that argument
um how they handle situations and then
you're like oh that's not you that's not
how you portrayed yourself to be and
they like they put up this image so
you're like oh
so why when the toxic stuff happens why
don't we leave right away because we're
so we're so like
no
i leave
it comes from experience yeah because as
a teenager i was dumb enough to stick
around i'm just like
it is
no i think it's like also attachment
issues like you're kind of attached to
what you have like for me in my
experience i can speak on it um for
example like for the first maybe a month
it was great and it was locked this is
locked down locked down so that when
kobe
[Music]
did not talk to several people during
the pandemic
you're lying because you can't you can't
go out you can't go wrong
with everybody i'm alright
as well like i was in my relationship
like lockdown like prior to right before
lockdown but then lockdown happened so
i'm stuck in that so you're in a bubble
as well
so it was like oh my god so i feel like
you get this facade and then you're kind
of
for example i lowkey have attachment and
she's hiking on the
that was like low-key big thing like so
it's like i'm like i'll be stick like
ride you through that and then it's like
you don't really see a lot of things
when you're kind of in this bubble
you're like you put them on this
pedestal like you're so attracted to
them like the problem is okay
no actually actually question is is the
toxic relationship that you were in the
best sex you've ever had yeah
no no no no
like do you ever hear like what you
shouldn't have is what is the best thing
like that you'll ever enjoy but what you
should do for yourself that's actually
what's actually best for you isn't
always easiest and that's why it's more
i'm sorry i had to do mental gymnastics
to get through that i'm sorry like
wait
wait actually
it was
it's like what's best for you is always
the hardest thing to do for you yourself
because it's like
you really need to go through the
hardest stuff you need all that
discipline
in order to really do what's best for
that it's never ever going to be easy i
think we always think it is like yeah we
can have easy sex and great sex with a
guy that's toxic but in five years or in
actually let me give you six months or
two more weeks
two weeks no actually
it's gonna it's gonna affect your life
it affects your mentality it affects how
your future relationships whether that's
a relationship with your future husband
um or actually your partner like girl
boy or your friendship it affects how
you act in that because that's where
trust issue stems from a lot of issues
do stem from that it could be from your
family other issues this is how it
starts so yeah so question for them they
come from good relationships good homing
good everything and they can get in the
talks and they can mess them up for the
toxic relationship you were in how long
were you in it
okay two months three four months
wow that that i care about
okay two months
it depends on which one i'm talking
about
but we're gonna talk about the worst one
yeah it took like two years two years
but it was codependency
you know chocolate two years on and off
though
two years
three months happening three months so
oh so you guys you're getting the
basketball girls leave
i told you as soon as you switch up i'm
not giving you another chance to switch
up on me i'm like bye
where he messed up and then i think he
tried to check me about that because he
felt so powerful around me like looked
like his phone or something and then i
was like i was like she being a
[Music]
i'm actually too good for this i think
for me to be fair like for that two-year
relationship that was when i was 18.
yeah i was like 18 19. so you know like
this was my first time in college being
with somebody like super close all the
time like because you know my parents
were on my ass like they're not gonna
let no boy come into the house oh yeah
so
it was like that codependency kicked in
very fast because i was around them all
the time and i just let [ __ ] slide and
he let [ __ ] slide on my end too
feel bad for him on that but yeah he
definitely did me worse than i did him
i'm not gonna lie to you
but i grew from that relationship and i
figured out how to get my [ __ ] together
and realize like i definitely deserve
way better than that so then did you
never have a toxic relationship again
since then no actually okay so for the
most part they were healthy
from that i feel like that's where we
actually need to play our like we need
to accept our part in this stuff we can
talk about toxic men who we like yeah
but toxic too okay
okay
man i know i definitely gone through my
man's phone like
wait wait out of everyone here how many
have gone through a guy's phone before
no never
i haven't since then not my phone so
basically with my
few months before months into it coming
up
that was the time i was like he was
acting so jealous and i was like why are
you acting so jealous like there must be
something you want to hide
so for the first time in my whole life
in my whole relationship life
i went through his laptop
okay what'd you find what happened to me
so you know how much an iphone syncs up
so i'm confident i'm like oh this is
your x thing this is your x i'm not
what's going on here i'm not my making
facetime calls and you're in a
relationship with me but i'm actually in
text messages i'm like no wait this is
crazy so i also feel like we do play our
plot like essentially like it takes two
mm-hmm i always believe that i would
never blame the guy for everything
that's happened now they ship the yeah
messi calls me mentally right because i
feel like i also enabled it tonight well
and we and we make a choice to stay so
you can't you can't say
yeah to make it work if you're after
until the point where you got paranoid
and i was like no if this when you're in
love you really forget what logic is yes
like your emotions really choose to
believe the better
therapists actually
literally will not take certain like
clients that are in love because your
brain chemistry is so different when
you're in that state of like love and
infatuation
so like and therapists also say like
cheating like goes two ways like you can
enable that behavior that brings someone
to that level where they cheat on you
you know they think it's okay like if we
allow them to think it's okay it's like
when you're a mom like if you allow your
child to fix certain behaviors okay
they're going to carry on doing it if
you don't check your child rip their ass
like they're going to be thinking it's
okay like you should have ripped your
sons off and maybe he would have been
better
so so next next question do you guys
have you guys ever stayed after cheating
yes i've never had that happen to me
remember you guys got it
being cheated on
yeah yeah yeah being being cheated on no
physically physically okay
yeah i definitely did but in the 18 year
old relationship yeah okay but to be
fair we were going through a difficult
time where we decided that we weren't
going to be together but we were still
stuck on each other all the time like we
weren't on the same page about where our
relationship was supposed to go and
whether we were fully together
and that created a lot of issues because
there was always miscommunications and
like you shouldn't be talking to that
[ __ ] but then you know he can though
like i can't stop him yeah so you guys
weren't actually together
exactly
what was you guys doing like sorry um
was you guys an official relationship
was that established we were at first
and [ __ ] got tough like i would go into
detail but it's like it's really really
personal you know like it's really tough
and i don't want to put him in a bad
spot if he saw this right now he'd be
like yo what's up
because we're actually friends now like
we grew so much and actually came
together and we're like yo i still got
love for you yeah like you're still my
homie like you were my best friend at
the end of the day and you were the
person that was there for me and through
every single bad thing that happened
we just weren't compatible
relationship-wise because we didn't know
how to communicate we didn't understand
what a relationship really meant yeah it
wasn't just loving someone hard and like
i thought i have something
it was actually communicating with each
other understanding what our problems
were with each other and yeah working
through that and each other as a person
exactly it's a whole different ballgame
relationship it is
do you okay next question okay
oh god have you had some [ __ ] [ __ ]
have you ever
slept with a toxic ex after you guys
broke up yeah yep
i wouldn't even cut make sure you're
grabbing
part of toxicity is like super high lies
right and then it's like you're chasing
that high right it's like an addiction
like yeah you're chasing those good
times
jess is like
[Music]
situation and it's like i think you hold
this expectation to how it's going to be
well that's what they do it doesn't end
up it doesn't end up like that but then
you're just you end up being so attached
to that person like you want that and
it's like do you know what i feel like
mentally to the point you can you get to
an extent you can be like that's all you
would expect from them because you know
what they really like like you know the
toxicity you mean in that situation you
came out of that you dealt with that you
moved past that you healed from that but
then it's like sexually do you know what
yeah you can do that for me
it's like but then i would and it's like
she's
actually you can satisfy me on that
certain perspective like aspect you can
like you know what in that area
you're you're great you're actually
you're effing
excuse me
you're top tier but then it's like
really intriguing do i really want that
energy inside you so that's why you go
there like you're like you know what you
are great like it's it's longer to go to
a different guy who doesn't know what
you like yeah like know how you are yeah
he doesn't he hasn't studied your body
yeah you haven't set you he won't set up
their body count that's another thing
there's a lot of aspects so you do go
there and you're like oh sex but it's
really not like it's really toxic sex
are you ending you're toxic and you're
going inside me now i'm toxic
it's actually
um okay pause really quick so we have
two super chats thank you so much guys
all donations are going towards eight
sets of mics we have four mics now and i
really want to make it eight so i need
another sound board which is my own guys
i need another donate donate donate
you know
so
so i need another sound board which is
about 500 and then each of these mics is
about 150 so it's about hey it's so
central donate donation anyways send
donations so i'm gonna i'm gonna read it
today i'm gonna do it today you'll be a
shout out on the youtube channel
so i'm gonna um i'm gonna read the super
chat so hl hls the beast relationship
status in ages so everyone go around so
i am 25 and i'm single
i'm looking slide into my dm
in a relationship
24 and single
27
and
that's how i'm going to say that's all
i'm going to say
make it what you want make it what you
want
how long now has it been
it'll be going on two months okay so
there are things oh really
you know how they say like religiously
like you know after like a year nah
she's like i know what two months that's
my yeah two months two months is my cut
off too much of my cut off so it's just
like i'm shocked about this one just
saying look
i keep my stuff private private
yeah i'm shocked too
ain't nobody gonna know
i'm trying to be like that you can be
open without detailing yeah you can but
it's just like you just got to be honest
i'm a bit
we're going to talk later
okay next next super chat pearl you've
had your mom on the channel a few times
her advice was to listen to your man and
always say yes to him sexually curious
to see if the panel would take that
advice oh so i'll take the [ __ ] down
my mom always said one of the reasons so
my parents have been married close to 30
years we i have nine siblings clearly
oh she was saying yes all the time
and that's one of the things she told me
she like i liked him it's awkward right
it's my mom but she was like to make
like i asked her like what are the keys
to like a long healthy marriage and she
said one of the keys like if you don't
want your husband to like step out is to
just always say yes because men have
like a higher sex drive than us okay
that is true but what if like one night
you're just tired and he's like hey babe
let's get it on you just said
cause that's where there's like mutual
respect factor though
yeah like you need to know like when's
the time to please your man and do a
thing for him but like vice versa yeah
if you don't want it like that then it
shouldn't be a [ __ ] conversation it
shouldn't be a yeah like it should be no
[ __ ] big yeah
i don't want to do that if you're with
someone that has gone through sexual
abuse in their life intimacy is a lot
different it's not just as simple as
let's have sex sometimes you know you
have bad days you have good days so
you need to be with a part of you like
personally i was sexually abused like
with like in
many different facets so like my partner
has to be very understanding with me
yeah
so the patient like i have a friend
who's mormon right so i don't know if
your your mom is specifically like
catholic catholic
i know you were but i don't know like
she's mormon her mom told her the same
thing told her the same thing and she
got into a situation where some things
happened with her man that she
wasn't you know i'm not gonna yeah yeah
yeah yeah but you get what i'm saying
it's like you have to have boundaries
for yourself as a woman like our body is
like
a temporary this is ours and it's sacred
like if you don't want it to be touched
if you don't want it right no it's not
but it's not but it's not in a way like
like she does it because she has to like
she loves my dad
yeah yeah
but that's the key though is that she's
okay with that if she doesn't feel
violated then it's okay by all means she
could do that as much as she wants
but
me speaking as somebody who's also been
sexually abused like i've been in that
position where it's like i feel
obligated to please my partner but i'm
not comfortable with it and it's like
they can clear clearly see the
discomfort in me and not respect that
then you start to wonder if they just
see you as a sexual being if they just
see you as a toy rather than an actual
person that experienced something so
terrible so yeah on the flip side do you
guys think there's ever a point where
it's like it's been too long
like because in my opinion like if you
haven't had sex with your husband in
like two or three years he's going
somewhere
i'm going to show my teeth like
like
me
like and i wouldn't even blame them like
i guys have to like do this
it's easy to write off men to be like
well they like they're [ __ ] animals
no they're they're human humans
i don't advocate cheating i've never
advocated i don't think it's cool to
cheat but what i'm saying is like i
think you have some level of
responsibility as a wife to have sex
with your husband i understand like so
if you haven't done it in like two or
three years like i think i would
understand if he left or told you he was
going to sleep
that's a part of being in a relationship
that's part of being in a relationship
two or three years that's different than
like if you go through like two or three
months where you're not having sex okay
yeah yeah
not only that how complicated is the
relationship or marriage for that person
to not want to be sexually active
that's the thing like what is he doing
that's making her uncomfortable have you
ever seen a couple where the girl feels
like she's settled and she's not really
into him but she just wants like kids
you've never seen that
but i'm saying
but i'm saying a lot of times the guy
doesn't know that
he doesn't know like who communicates
i'm with you i don't advocate cheating
but i would understand if he wanted to
get a divorce on the grounds he hasn't
had sex in three years if he vocalized
that divorce and that separation issues
and then cool down his thing
fair enough yeah if he was to go be
petty and be like cool i haven't got
anything for my wife you might not even
know the reason why station got abused
or kidnapped or something
she didn't feel comfortable to tell you
she didn't want you to look at her a
certain way what is understanding but
whatever you jumped to be communication
yeah definitely but it's still lack of
communication was his part like he could
never say he was in the right emotional
world
no i'm with you i don't agree with
cheating like i'm never going to
advocate for cheating i don't think it's
cool to cheat
but i understand like where men are
coming from when they haven't like
because they're all that happens a lot
they'd be getting [ __ ] and still go
ahead god go ahead also i think it's
important to know like in the day and
age we're in there's temptation
everything everywhere let me tell you if
you have a fine man or a fine woman
there are people waiting
waiting
patiently waiting so it's like you kind
of do like you know okay also like i'm
not saying women aren't but men are a
lot more like visual yeah women we're a
lot more internal emotional what are you
doing for me like like an exchange of
like goods almost like what are you
doing that kind of turns us off yeah the
things you can like almost give us in a
way but like men are like they'll see
something and they want it and they're
like oh sparkly like
well they're they're more they're more
visual
and also sex doesn't have like like it's
it's not as much to them as it is
as a woman i'm not gonna get a dick pic
and be like
god but he's a man like he's going to
get a picture of a kid
and he's going to be like i need to [ __ ]
this [ __ ] right now so it's like as a
woman
you have to kind of be aware of that
like [ __ ] are lurking yeah
i feel like they should hold their own
issue it's about if what you want like
if you really want this say i'm a man
i've got my partner if i want my man
enough
no other guy will tell me that i could
maybe look at grandpa oh yeah you'll
find this part i don't mean i want you
though essentially or you can just you
guys are attracting
but i might think yeah you're attractive
i could even think just as attractive
doesn't mean i
want her yeah and i could have a man
well do do you think cheating
do you think do you think cheating is
different for men and women
really
um the principle is the principle no no
we're not we're not talking about we're
not talking about the principle though
so what i'm saying cheating is different
for men and women i think men can have
sex with someone they don't even like
and never want to see again we're girls
just like you're here
i could do that too
but naturally men kissed like
i'll just have like you know what i'm
saying like i've been in space where i
don't even need to like
yeah do you do you feel like that's the
norm because i don't feel like that's
what is the norm
what like who defines that norm i mean
statistics and
i was going to say that men are very
much heat of the moment type of cheaters
and when it comes to women it sometimes
can be more on the emotional side
because when you have a partner that you
love dearly but you feel like you're not
getting enough from them emotionally you
might try to find that out elsewhere and
that becomes a problem and that's why
oftentimes men feel like it's worse when
girls cheat because they're like damn
that man is emotionally available okay
and like you know my girls because
because
because
women
from what i've seen tend to cheat up so
like if they're cheating it's like
there's a wreath
today
earlier like oh we have to be worried
about the ugly girl like you know you
know because men will sleep with like
goddamn anything but like women like if
you're cheating from what i've seen like
usually the guy that they're cheating
with has something the partner doesn't
have where the girl if he cheats it's
like she'll have nothing to say yeah
yeah
yeah i i have cheated before hi nice to
meet you
i never said i was a good person
so in my experience it was like mentally
i was done like i didn't want to be with
you [ __ ] anymore like
i was
no i'm so serious like i was like so
done and like it just he wouldn't leave
me alone and i kept trying to break up
with him the nice way and then it was
like i felt stuck
it for certain reasons and then i would
just like mentally i was done i cheated
and i was like i don't care anymore
because you've hurt me in so many ways
emotionally that's brought me to this
point where
i don't care and like now
looking back yes i regret those actions
because that's not right i could have
just put my foot down and not been a
weak [ __ ] and then like i don't want to
be with you which i actually did do and
he just like would tell me no
don't know how the [ __ ] that was
probably like when my therapist told me
i was bipolar and i told her no
but you know like i feel like
for me personally not speaking for all
women but it was like uh i didn't care
like because i was done i would left the
relationship mentally way before i
cheated
i feel like some women when they do
cheat it's not like
initially or like when they
it's not the intention yeah it'll be
like
build up so they'll start talking to
somebody they'll be they'll be fed
emotionally and then it gets to that
point where it's like okay i'm gonna
have sex with you and i feel like not
all women but i feel like that emotional
like
boundary is like set and then they like
keep building and then it ends up that's
why that's why i watch the male friends
go out and do whatever they just pull up
to the club and they're like all right
i'm taking you off
and then the other half are just like
i'm not getting what i need yeah i need
i need to be fed somewhere else okay
i think there's a lot of stereotypes as
well like
i gotta i gotta pause for one second we
can hold on so um next super chat sam
mendimassa
hashtag
just lined up you would be shocked okay
like so you got [ __ ]
yeah yeah
like i know what you're gonna say like
like like so many it's like i can't
anyways um
also the british girl is fine af he
thinks you're fine yes
um i am in a domestic discipline
relationship with my man what is that
what is your opinion on dd relationships
i'm the happiest i've ever been karissa
wilson i've heard it okay so
i think that is um i saw this on i think
it was
not lifetime but it was like
my life or whatever on
vh1 or something
and it was this couple who um
the guy the man in the relationship they
were married disciplined his wife and
gave her rules and like if you didn't
follow this she would either have to
write like an essay or something or
write things down or be punished in a
way i don't know i'm not sure if that's
her type of it's like that's the type of
[Applause]
it says domestic discipline is a
relational approach that advocates
wifely submission and male dominance
through the use of disciplinary tactics
such as spanking
i can actually speak on this because i
am part of that but
however it's not always like male
dominance female submissiveness like
it's not always that dynamic especially
because right now i'm with a woman
so like we kind of like switch on and
off rules with that but we more so do
that in a positive light i don't know
how to explain it because it's not like
you didn't make me a sandwich yeah yeah
go write a [ __ ] essay like nah like
you're whipping them or something
it's like
it's like the way that we do it is by
uplifting each other like it's like you
didn't do your affirmations today like
you did not speak highly of yourself
today
i will come back to you in 10 minutes
like make sure you do it
but you're not
me and my girlfriend have automations on
for each other where it says like yeah
affirmations where it's like i'm
powerful i'm beautiful so on and so
forth because we try to uplift each
other as much as we can yeah so i know
what it's like to be in that type of
relationship both sexually and like
outside of a sexual um viewpoint but
what about like the
like the more strict like let's say you
started dating griller guy and they said
this is the strict like rules for you
they have to develop that connection
with me in order for me to get that far
but you could possibly get that far
that's what i mean yeah okay like that's
what i'm talking about what about you
yeah i feel like i that's to me that's
kind of hot but like i've never been
with a guy
let me ask that
i like to throw them down
oh i've been with too many guys
i feel like i've never been with a man
that like i'm a very dominant female
energy like i always i also just have
control issues because [ __ ] that's
happened in my life i feel like i always
need to be like in control also i'm a
leo so that's just [ __ ] up
oh my goodness
gemini gemini i don't follow them
okay finish your thought finish your
thoughts what was like so you were
saying you think it's hard you would you
think it'd be hot because i've never
been with a man that has been able to
have like be able to handle me like that
and so i feel like that's something that
i want because like i haven't no one's
been able to handle me
so what i'm hearing is
they [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh wow i'm here it sounds like well
they're they're like not you know what
are they called the alpha and the beta
so it's like more of a beta i know
we do not know okay
you know what i'm saying when i'm
commuting like you know what i'm talking
about you could say more feminine
whatever go ahead i feel like personally
sometimes i'm like is it my fault
because do i like like subconsciously
seek out weak men not like weak but like
men that are just like no he's like
controls yes is it me am i the talker
am i the drama yeah
what about what about you guys would you
guys be cool with a relationship like
that no
but you're not actually telling me but
okay so
not
in the sense where it's like i feel like
i'm being punished but the way that you
explained it i would like an uplifting
type of relationship to where it's like
both like where i can step ahead and
then like let you lead and everything
what if what if you're at a you're at a
guy's house right
and then you just meet the man
no you've been dating right and he you
did something he didn't like
and he says if you do that again i need
you to leave
okay
well like did i like overstep a boundary
yeah probably it was something he's
setting a boundary this is the first
time you did something he found
disrespectful i don't you could but
so he said if you're gonna do this like
i'm not telling you to leave now but if
you do this again i like i'm gonna need
you to leave okay because you're not
getting proper communication yeah yeah
yeah at first it sounded like the man
was just like get the [ __ ] out like you
just pissed me like if you
[Music]
for me that's communication like you're
like you're setting me boundaries yeah i
like it or not that's you setting me
boundaries i need to respect that
because because you're a human being you
can set that boundary you're entitled to
that for example if i set those
boundaries you need to respect that like
if you've told me if you did that again
that's not cool that's what you want
from what i from my relationship that's
what you're from a relationship
regardless that's me or another girl or
another woman whatever that's what you
want so i need to respect that if i
can't adhere to that
that's on me
but it's different if you if i just mess
up one time and you're like you know
what get the [ __ ] out you're abusing me
verbally
physically abusing me like all of that
that's different but for you to vocalize
how you feel
and i'm still doing it again that's
different okay next question do you
associate more masculine guys with being
toxic
or do you see masculinity as different
from toxicity the term toxic masculinity
is often made
vague
are nice guys seen as softer and more
feminine
oh okay there's a lot to unpack here
there's a lot to unpack here i
definitely
but
this is me being a little more pro male
which is off brand for me but
like they're toxic masculinity
especially in sports is like
all of us
[Music]
like for me i've only ever been with
athletes and like the culture that's set
for them like
they're not allowed to process their
emotions and
in that way it's like it causes it it
makes it builds up a wall for them
because it's like if they show emotion
in that way they're weak and that's what
they've been told their whole life like
you cry you're a [ __ ]
to me when a man when a man cries and
like
well depends what they're crying about
but like
but like that's like vulnerable and like
to me that strength like if you're able
to because there is such a culture like
you know oh
don't be a don't be a [ __ ] like that's
what they'll say to like men yeah like
don't be a [ __ ] and like also like
that's kind of [ __ ] up
on the flip side so a common complaint i
hear from guys is women say they want
the emotional side from us like they say
they want us to cry in front of them
they say they want it but then we give
it to them
and they're not attracted to it and they
don't like it so women don't really know
what they want exactly do you think
that's true
i've seen that i saw i saw that in a
video it was this guy
uh i don't know what he was upset about
or crying about but um the girl was like
she was on the phone with him and she
was like i want you to be more
vulnerable with me but not like this and
he's like pouring out his heart yeah
just come hiding in her and then i
thought about like what you just asked
us like where's there like a cut-off
tour it's like okay i want you to be
vulnerable but not that long before you
look like a baby but it's like but like
where does it like stop i was gonna say
i think it depends on the situation at
all times because if i see you
crying over somebody dying or like
feeling like the way like the weight on
your shoulders is too much like i want
to be there for you to help you lift
that weight off your shoulders and make
you feel exactly but
if
you see a rat in the corner of the room
and you start crying yeah i'm gonna let
me like like no because even i'm not
gonna do that like i do
i feel like i'll cry as well so i'd be
like no i'll be crying but i fall out
man the hell up
can you just
like handle
your business yeah yeah yeah just
personal preference like what are you
attracted to like i know i definitely
have internalized like toxic masculinity
like i am very like
when a guy shows me like little signs of
like being like a little feminine that's
a huge turnoff i like
it i don't know why
you like that stuff oh my gosh no i see
a man on a crop top oh no
it's not toxic masculinity
it is not toxic masculinity to have a
preference for men that are men can i
sorry i'm sorry okay so
they're not any less a man just because
they're dressed
i think you're more masculine am i a man
just because i'm wearing pants ooh are
you what is that i am i don't know
feeling because i wear pink well i do
yeah
pants are more masculine basketball
shorts are more matte like you look more
masculine when you wear that stuff men
tend to be more expensive
for that like why does it yeah if you
wear the baggy shorts like basketball
kit wise why does it mean i'm more
masculine do you know what i mean
because you look like like it's like
common sense
sexuality that's not coming to be like
what i mean
i could wear a salmon shirt
i'm in a salmon um shirt that means i'm
feminine well i mean not just a pink
shirt it's like how you dress like i
think it's common sense that a girl in a
ball gown looks more feminine and a girl
in a basketball jersey i think it looks
more
matter i don't think it's security i
think it's common sense like i think
like come on you guys know what i'm
saying is true
you're telling me you're telling me
cinderella cinderella
looks more masculine
yeah it's more matte like girls look
more masculine in our basketball jerseys
i wear
so if a guy comes to me in a crop top he
looks more feminine i'm not attracted to
elliot looks real good
you'll be saying oh i look more
masculine yeah yeah cause typically
that is
but like
the world we live in see this is where
society's standards coming i feel like
personally to my in my opinion your
opinions
don't get too yeah it's wrong yeah i
just feel like personally we're in a
world that's more evolved where back in
the day yes football and basketball are
sports that's more associated with
men
and women have worked their asses off
their bloody ass stuff i'm trying not to
swear guys um to get to where they are
the level of where they are for example
i even had an argument with a guy that
said one of the girls on your team um
plays like a guy and i argued with him
and i was like yo why don't you play
that many times
why does she play do you think because
men are better no
sorry
they are yes i'm
like statistically in every category in
every sorry physically scientifically
yeah
so by every measure that you get every
piece of data that you can measure and
then
to get to the standard of basketball
uh-huh that she plays she's a pro player
yeah yeah and the guy said she plays
like a guy that's so degrading she
rocked her ass off to get to where she
plays i think that's degrading but she
looks like a woman it's that's something
who she is it's not even about women or
men but why is it why is it degrading if
men are bad like they're better because
why would you prepare me to remember
[Music]
okay this is my platform this is my this
is my youtube show pipe down child
respectfully
like why does it matter like why is your
first instinct to get angry when men are
like if we compare if we compare men to
women like they don't get angry like why
is your first so
because they don't want to be
comfortable like femininity being pinned
on them
and we
like but
like basketball right men statistically
in every single i'm sorry it's not a fun
reality but statistically like like in
every single category are better than
women like there's
like really good high school teams that
beat wnba teams all the time
like
but we we want credit yeah
we want we could cut out the comparison
of being seen as a man so what if what
if i said you fight what if i say you
play like lebron james would you be
offended no because
so
i wouldn't i wouldn't be offended but
i'd be like so
my
my gifts and my talents are overlooked
to be compared to
an nba player yes
great nba player but i'd be like can i
not be can i not play like jessica can i
not play like me i understand what
you're saying but just the fact that
women can't be be like oh she's a great
player she she plays like herself like i
wonder how long she took the train about
a lot to get there but to be compared to
a man it's like okay why can't i why
can't i give you compared to lisa
i just don't understand why it's a bad
thing if they're if they're good like
we just i don't i don't think it's as
women like me personally i can say i got
complimented in the comparison of a
woman right and that was the best
feeling in the world because i was
playing beach volleyball one day yeah
and this guy on the court was like oh
you're black serena williams but in
volleyball yeah i was like but you were
you you but you weren't offended by that
because because she was a woman and she
paved away for female
like in the in college basketball
women's take losses every year in
profits who's making
when it comes to money i mean just being
strong enough to want to play a sport
that is male dominated for example like
come on tennis uh basketball all those
things
it always started out with men at some
point they were like all right let's let
women play even baseball they decided
not to let women play baseball and call
it softball yeah
because they decided to be different
like don't the only time i feel like
it's okay to make extreme
comparisons and differences in the sport
is track that makes sense women are
naturally built different we fully
accept that
so we have to make those exceptions for
us and track but in other sports give
women a little bit more credit you know
we we haul ass too
so they hold it down
yeah like if we look at there's a lot of
women there's a lot of female like if
we're going to talk about basketball or
anything we're probably coming to
volleyball i don't really
but like even in basketball um even
football
there's a lot of female players that
actually play better than a lot of men
plays but you never say you'll never
catch like a other guy crediting them
like that like but
wait are you talking about soccer yeah
yeah yeah are you talking about soccer
but if the women
if the women it's all driven by the
market though like it's driven by by the
fans that want to watch so so if if
women weren't better than men like more
fans would watch they would make more
money into the sport later
is like
not the right term like i think that
like historically like male sports have
dominated and that's kind of the tone
that's set like yeah we can have like a
40 year yeah exactly right like also
women we don't play like men we play
differently we're correct yes business
and that's genetics yeah we are like
volleyball it's completely different
because then men's volleyball yeah yeah
yeah women's volleyball is a lot less
like men's volleyball they'll have two
rallies and then it's over because
everyone hits so hard that you can only
do so much with it yeah women's
volleyball is a lot different and that
like there's a lack of interest like
women's basketball you're not going to
see girls dunking every single ball
right
that's not the showboat like you know
what i'm saying so yeah yeah i'm like i
agree i agree yeah i don't appreciate
the i think
i think it's because like
obviously men are gonna be better
because testosterone is a thing yeah
they just have more right it's also it
makes them more emotional fun facts yeah
i saw that on this again and so
but i think it's just the point of like
we we already know men are going to be
physically more better than yeah but why
do we have to have that comparison they
may be a great player they may be a
great athlete but why can't there's also
great athletes as women why can't i be
compared to a woman why do i have to be
compared to a man and so i think i'd
rather be compared to a guy in
basketball because they're better but
they're but there's great but there's no
man like if they said you play like like
lebron james i'd be like dope that's the
best basketball player in the world
no i would pick lebron he's better small
person yeah
yeah completely your opinion yeah yeah
you know what i'm saying it's fine it
doesn't like matter yeah
yeah yeah i know that when i was a
teenager and i first started in
volleyball like i was constantly
compared to guys yeah like initially
because i had a very masculine and
aggressive way of playing as opposed to
just straight tactics so it makes sense
but i did take it as a compliment like i
never had an issue with it because i was
just like gang [ __ ] like yeah
when it came to a point where i realized
like
men don't have to be the pinnacle of
power like that's what it is like i'm
a little tired of that narrative like i
want i don't see it i don't think it's
the narrative i see women in media all
the time
like i see women in like and and online
it's changing i see women definitely
yeah so i don't i don't see men as being
like the pinnacle of like 80 of consumer
buying decisions are by women so we're
all like we are constantly being
marketed for women i feel like i'm just
tired of like okay like when you look at
like commercials in the way that um
sports are showed with like men for
example it's always like them with
gatorade and they're like yeah yeah feel
the burn like not really
like you see a tampax commercial and
it's like damn bro like
more than our periods please you can do
your whole life on your period the only
time that you see again like i mentioned
before serena williams like that's like
one of the only athletes that you see in
these commercials like going hard and
going big and it's not about that
the girl from track was just in it the
girl from the track team was just in it
the us the us sorry i haven't simone
like
no she's not from track wait wait
it's simone
i was just saying that like they're like
like serena williams like she is so
overly sexualized because she has like a
big ass and she's like a curvy girl and
she's attractive like that bothers me
too because it's like it doesn't focus
on her skill she's insane oh she isn't
sleeping
absolutely
be like sexualized in a tennis match
it's like okay i'm gonna start
sexualizing men your balls look real
good jiggly
touching on that touching on that there
was a coach i can't remember where she
was from but it was breast cancer
awareness and she had on pink leather
pants and a white top
nothing good she looked great but
someone said is this inappropriate for a
coach i'm like why is that what does it
do
what if a dude wore tight pants and you
could see stuff and like is that
inappropriate i hate to bring in racism
it's also a racial thing often times
always sexualize black women and at the
same time masculinize us it makes no
sense and then discriminates against it
it's like what do you want because you
know you really want all of that
if you're gonna constantly sexualize us
like get it together dog like we are not
just
i don't know i don't care
okay wait so the next the next
appreciate sorry i gotta i gotta move on
to the next super chat um okay the
average guy lasts what 10 to 15 minutes
you can't spare an hour a week don't be
surprised when he steps out not cheating
at that point sir it's still cheating um
but thank you for the super chat you i'm
not okay i'm not gonna
get off the live um
find something else to do my love it's
okay okay like
if you want to hate maybe hate somebody
somewhere else this coach
but
i've worn i've worn jeans like that and
i've worn him i think i think an
organization has every right to like
have their standards whatever they want
them to be so
like like there's a dress code like make
it easy yeah like make it even for guys
and girls
why is that also like what
with that it's like well there has to be
a line somewhere well
what what can she wear because she's
like yeah pants like this and it's still
going to hug her like that yeah what she
wanted what do they want her to wear a
dress
i i get that like i just all i'm saying
is there has to be a line somewhere like
and the question is where do you draw it
because yeah yeah because i don't expect
you to play
basketball
i'm here to coach now
okay okay
um okay okay like
it's still a professional outfit and you
know
if it was someone who was less
curvaceous and she would not have gotten
that she would not have gotten that
never any white female coach with no
curves this that would not have ever yes
never never ever it would not have
circulated okay never be vulnerable fix
the problem then talk dion lewis thank
you sir um
pearl never change
ten dollars from black ups thank you
all super chats okay will be given
towards the soundboard i'm not even
taking any money you guys send right now
it's all being donated towards the new
sound board four more mics then i could
have eight [ __ ] in here
if you're entertained now imagine eight
of us maybe maybe even bring in some men
you know um guys she needs help
eight people yeah and and 50 super chat
we're all gonna take a shot
don't send it don't send it
i'll do it
you'll do it for the cause except i
don't drink so i won't but they will
sorry first of all
[Music]
for us to take a shot and you don't even
drink look at it look at it
hold on
cheers
[Music]
right now oh [ __ ] i forgot
uh jess rolled her ankle in practice
i actually want to make myself a proper
drink i don't want to just take a shot
because shots are nasty okay the gray
pill podcast i've never even heard of
gray pill
love the lady
it's that one who's got sorry oh you
this is about you love the lady with the
ponytail she can carry herself well i'd
vibe with here
um okay do any okay next super chat from
josh
e
ethernall ethernal um do any of you find
roman
reigns sexy we'll pull him up on the
screen i don't know i don't know
what's in my head is like the [ __ ] um
um let's see
oh
[Music]
he's not my type yeah i wouldn't say
that i would like be with him but he's
he has a nice face i like long hair
typically
do we know
his ethnicity
this guy this guy on the screen this
never ever changed
why does that sniff
if he's not someone that's incorrect oh
well you could you could just say he
looks like is he polly
i mean suffer i can't speak like
it says he's
[Music]
that shot got you real fast
yeah anyone in the chat let's see
but what was
that what was it what were they what was
their question i don't think they had it
i didn't think they had any so far if we
find him attractive was that the thing
yeah if you found him attract all right
smash your pass that guy everyone
i have another question that i just
thought of now
how long is too long to stay in the
talking stage
define talking stage so you're not an
official relationship but you're like
hooking up
and spending a lot of time together
i think
depends on the person so much
i wouldn't define it by time oh yeah i
feel like that's all it's all personal
it's all relative
like what she said like yeah if you guys
are communicating enough like say i'm
dating a guy like this is where the
dating stage comes in like if you're
dating a dating a guy or your partner i
don't want to
specif like a guy or girl
thank you guys
a shout out to you guys like a guy or
girl if you're dating your partner like
a person a human being um i feel like it
just depends on your connection where
you are where you are okay but there's
okay but there's always going to be a
line right so we can we can see where
you're at here all right
for example like
long like long distance like us being
here and then being in america like
maybe
dating
exclusively isn't what's working so it's
like maybe you're gonna talk for a while
and then
i don't know okay i feel like a year
talking for me personally that would be
like no
so a year what do you say how long is
too long um
i really think it depends on the
strength of the relationship but i will
say speaking from my current
relationship her and i were actually
talking for a long time like i would say
like six months and i'm not that kind of
person typically i want to date like not
right away but like maybe after a month
or two like i feel like all right what
are we doing at this point
but she was willing to be patient enough
with me because i was healing from
whatever was going on in my past
relationship and she was very patient
and when i was finally ready like she
was like want to get in a relationship
you know i asked her to be my girlfriend
and things worked out just fine for us
it's a very healthy beautiful
relationship we try our best we try our
best
here's the thing we did um break up
recently but then got back together
we just had like a really really rough
situation yeah
she
wrote literally she saw where she went
wrong in this situation because like it
was more so something i had a problem
with and she took responsibility gave me
a long-ass apology
and would do she sent me a dozen roses
and my favorite chocolates and a card
because she wants me to know like she's
in it for me she wants to know that she
loves me
um so knowing that she's so patient with
me and understanding and i do the same
for her like that's a really healthy
relationship and that doesn't typically
happen like most people can't
communicate so yeah so what if you did
that for a year do you think you still
would have kept talking i think so yeah
with her so absolutely anybody else
probably not probably not no problem
because her and i were already in a
long-distance relationship back home she
lives in maryland and i'm in new jersey
jess i want to hear what you have to say
how long is too long
i think
for talking and then i have a question
for everyone what's talking mean though
can i can i ask i'm just defined
like real yeah just super fast i feel
like a lot of these questions like me
too we're all going into like personal
like whatever right like we need to look
at it more like hypothetical or just
like like if you've just met someone or
like you start like not thinking about
like i think that it all depends on the
situation because i've known people who
have
met somebody and during the pandemic
they
talked all the time and the talking
stage was maybe like a few weeks and
they started dating or a few months and
they started dating i think it just
depends on the situation how much time
you do spend with that person to get to
know them so in this situation you're
seeing them a couple times a week you're
sleeping there sleeping with them like
let's say three three to four times a
week
yeah yeah
how
how long is too long in general i know
there's specific instances like that's
always gonna be but like in general
i think that
too long is
if i'm spending two three times a week
with you you should know me by
the end of like i would say three four
months six months to a year
and it may be too long
you apparently get to know like the
person fully who they are after three
months so it only makes sense to get
into a relationship after three months
yeah like you should not exceed that
point and just yeah they're trying to
get to know each other because right did
you know me yeah you know me i've been
with you three days right i've been with
you
then i mean yeah you probably did pretty
well okay what about you what about you
can i just say you know when you said oh
like following up for me you said
um
you get to know someone after two three
months i think i
i personally disagree with that i think
you get to know someone to an extent i
feel like it's not a relationship
surprisingly that's definitely that's
really talking about stages you know
them to a certain point and then you get
in the relationship and then you really
want to get to know someone before you
get into that relationship before you
fully you're committing yourself to that
it's not marriage it's a relationship
you can end tomorrow
society right yeah like what if i chose
to really connect with you and talk to
you
and date you for maybe a year hold on
wait hold on
i know you girls like to tussle but you
pull out your blocks basically yeah i
hold it for a year but then maybe i
might find something about you about
11 months into it and i might be like
whoa
that's crazy that's actually crazy you
actually handled that like that say that
that ongoing stuff save it
like what is within that you would
communicate with them like exactly yo i
didn't like the way do not go and write
but say they're still stuff that they're
not showing you because
early on but there's always it doesn't
matter people are married to people they
don't know there is always going to be
some fear of the unknown but like would
you want to live your life in fear of
like one thing
like that why wouldn't it but why
wouldn't you try why don't you like go
into the relationship and try not to try
to still at least control the narrative
on your part like but sometimes you
can't control that i don't get into a
relationship you three months into it
like no one no you can't take
communication conversation
but i think it's the same like don't
don't guess that's my full opinion like
it could be like i could get into a
relationship with two months and then
find out something to one week after i
get into that relationship with him like
oh no the same for me
but i think it works i don't think
there's a definitive answer i think
gabby wanted to say something next do
you still have it
oh you were you were just like putting
her i don't know i was i think she
wasn't
getting she had a green eyes who just
might not like that [ __ ] if it's
going to take you that long to get into
it
that's just the way that i see it you
just are not committed like you it's
like you want to try and force yourself
to like them but at the end of the day
if it's not there it's not there
and i just know mentally but like then
what are you waiting for
someone better you're already at that
point in a relationship
logically i think
has everyone ever thought that like with
their brain instead of their heart and
their [ __ ]
clearly not we've all been in toxic
relationships
okay okay okay um next super chat
remember guys
all donations are going towards more
mics don't don't make gabby share mike
next time
let me let me order
all night
if you donate fifty dollars
pearl will take a half a shot
[Music]
next super chat great show i would
advise a wooden table to help cut down
on the noise otherwise i can see you
building something special here for sure
okay thank you
thank you
donate so i can afford the table
absolutely
please
specifically on the table with a hole in
the middle
yeah part no it won't fit all the mics
um okay okay the next the next the next
one is can pearl can we get each of the
ladies to do the female delusion
calculator oh my god
first of all the website was broken the
last time i was okay okay we're gonna
we're gonna do it for fun before you
talk about how much you hate it
i didn't say i hated it i said the
website was down
[Music]
i
yeah okay can we can we explain what
this is okay okay so age range without
you let's start with you because you
don't know what it is yeah i don't know
okay so what's the age range you would
date
we'll start off with the
lowest i'll go 24. okay highest uh
37. okay
do you look that's 10 years older than
me my parents are 10 years apart
i'm not i'm good up to 15. um what about
race
do you care
based on the the options i have i'm
going to choose the black okay
okay
minimum minimum
minimum height
six we'll keep it at six okay
what's the minimum income
six figures that's my type six figures
i'm kidding
it's just
go up go up go go
uh we'll go we'll leave it there 70.
yeah okay i don't know if that's low or
high
you know 45 is average oh okay i'll be
making my own money so okay so so 70
that's your final answer yeah
okay
the probability of you finding this guy
is this one point is point two three
percent
how cause fifty percent are married
oh yeah
mean honestly
i'm the what
oh yeah
i'm the type of person that
i've come to the realization like if i
find that person or if they find me cool
but if not i'mma live my life by myself
like exactly
i'm cool the happiest people
statistically are women who are single
yeah that's not true that's not true
that's not true
it's like the lowest female happiness is
women over the age of 50 with no kids
okay that's 50. um we talk about our age
group i'm not 50.
i feel like though like so like my older
sister she's 29 right and like you're 27
like that's not too far off yeah i know
when she was your age she started
feeling like i'm on a time crunch
like whatever that but it's like 30 is
the new 20 like
you're so young like and it's good that
you got to that point in your life where
you're like i don't care yeah but listen
you're young you're stunning you're
smart because you're sexy you're
talented intellectually
that will come i wouldn't even i'm like
when i was younger like it's like not
built into you but it's just so like
drilled into you like oh you're boaz
when you're in church and whatnot they
like tell you like oh this is gonna find
you don't look for it and you're just
like okay i'm gonna i'm gonna look at
the cabinet and then like it comes to
that age where it's like okay
i planned on this happening this time it
hasn't happened and i've just come to
the realization like when it's supposed
to happen it's supposed to happen and
that's how i am you guys do you guys do
you guys feel like it's just supposed to
happen or do you feel like you're
supposed to put in work to find a
partner
i don't think you could i didn't think
you should choose i don't think you
should force it i think it was for you
i'm a huge believer of that i think
that's just my belief but i feel like
you also have to put in that work it's
that manifestation i think people think
if you say thing that i'm going to be
rich one day like you're going to say
it's like yeah but you need to create
that word yeah yeah you depend on words
and connect with that universe and
connect with what you want and what you
believe in and what you want for your
life so so you do what happened
but do you think it's the same thing for
a husband if you want to get married yes
okay okay yeah yeah
because like if i wanted to get married
in the next year i just hire a
matchmaker
if i want to get married in the next
year that is absolutely wrong
i was gonna say outside of that um
you have to understand if you are ready
for a relationship because you could be
pushing as hard as you want going
through five six different talking
stages and it's like at some point you
have to realize like maybe you're not
ready yeah maybe it's not the time for
you so just let it go focus on yourself
do what you have to to make yourself the
best you can be at your own standard and
then maybe it will come around also so
just don't do you guys do you guys think
what gabby said was true um around like
27 to say 30 like women start to get
like kind of more rushed i think that
it's just with
society they're like oh thirty yeah your
eggs are drying up venus is like no i
know people who have had kids close to
forty or after forty and then you know
yeah
well you had my brother at forty two
yeah literally like three years old so
well you guys realize like like the
there's a lot of companies that are
saying 55 of women today and 10 like are
going to be single and childless like at
40. because of the way society's like
going no it's that society yeah what the
hell am i going to do
well i'm gonna start popping out the
babies for everybody yeah make them no
problem
well no i'm just i'm just like statistic
like
i like let's think like worlds like yeah
like sorry in the united states you're
right there's a lot of issues like i
know a lot of people that don't want
kids because of the way our world has
been going yeah so i think that may have
but why why is it like that the world's
going like we have a lower rate of
poverty than we ever have had in the
entirety of human history really
we're not getting paid as much as we
should no because the way the inflation
has gone up so inflation's bad yeah
we're not getting paid more so it's like
like right you're right you're
outrageous
my parents my parents right able to buy
a house right right out of college
that is impossible like in our day and
age it's impossible it's just not gonna
happen we could barely pay rent like
with just a regular job like with no
experience and coming out of college
like you know it's just not there's a
a lot of
things in the way that weren't in the
way tend to so you're saying you're
saying like a lot of people well but the
other problem is like consumer debt
and like that's like 80 of consumer debt
is owned by women so like women aren't
like good at saving
so it's like partially like our own
fault if we're in a problem where you
have 80 like 80 like because the other
genders aren't doing it i think men are
more concentrated on like when it comes
to money management so i don't think it
depends on family as well so also like
just recently started having our own
bank accounts isn't it that a woman
couldn't open a bank account until like
shortly after
uh voting was
yeah yeah but
what does that have to do with us today
like i i don't know
no no no i'm sorry no no this is that
had nothing to do with me something that
happened in the 20s i felt like i'm like
20 that was only 30 is for even let's
say 50s 60s i wasn't alive you can't you
can't believe you're spending you can
know you cannot blame your spending
habits let me finish talking i let you
talk a lot jessica
baby
listen at the end of the day
being a woman of color
when it comes to money and all that
we're a lot more careful about this kind
of stuff because i was 19. you know our
history does not prove well when it
comes to finances and education you know
and we're trying to work better it's
something that should be taught in
schools like financial literacy
investing and luckily in my high school
yeah we needed at least two years of
financial literacy classes yes so
but you know when you have half of the
country not even being able to read at a
sixth grade level
it's gonna get kind of hard for us to
have
uh understanding of both reading and
money like
i think that
one reason why that statistic that you
shared is so low
amongst women
is um
you like spark something it's because
that
we
it shared
more like financial literacy and correct
me if i'm wrong it's shared more with
people who are wealthy wealthy yeah
already wealthy and that typically comes
from the caucasian community and it's
something that isn't well i'm talking
about like women only in conclusion yeah
yeah that's what i'm saying like okay
you have to bring up that intersection
but i'm saying like even if it's like
the wealthy people have that knowledge
like they
um like it's half women like
yeah but i'm saying just like the
dynamic of whatever community you come
from i don't know the statistics yeah
yeah yeah that might come from this
community that community but it's
very um
it's not talked about yeah it's not
talked about it as much and i can
understand why that would be
low because of just the dynamics do you
feel like the the internet though is
kind of the great equalizer because you
have access to all this information that
like like you can you can look up like a
billionaire giving someone financial
advice yeah i do think that
you can access anything and everything
on the internet but if it's not
something that you grew up with you've
been taught like this is important like
financial literacy you need to
understand it you're not gonna look it
up on your own i just from what i've
seen i don't think it's like a community
thing like i think women just spend
money on like clothes and like like like
more like looks yeah like like i think
women just have worse spending habits
than yeah and i do think that and i
think it's been
made possibly
as well yeah like men that we're the
ones who are going to consume this kind
of stuff how often do you see forever 21
talking about the men's section yeah
that's what i'm saying
our whole media is like marketed towards
women everything you see is like for a
female audiences into a corner except
for this show keep up winning
always wanting to
tell me something yeah
yeah it becomes an issue in society can
i say something
yeah go ahead i
disagree with that to an extent
let's not get damn she just [ __ ]
shooting me left her right
you're on my left right now
she said left and right so
i'm playing go ahead hold on um i think
i disagree with that to an extent i
can't like personally i'm not running
that i care about how i look but i think
this was my passion for fashion right
mm-hmm
that's a personal thing
but i think in terms there's a lot of
guys males that are very invested in how
they look a lot more than women whereas
women can think it's wrong statistically
you're wrong
you're thinking of exceptions about the
role you're thinking
you're wrong
yeah men will make a big purchase
culture and preference mm-hmm as well
like what you want as a person as well
yeah like for example like you can just
want to dress because you want to dress
up there's a there's an artist like
she's not in the fashion business she's
actually an artist
but
plays about in fashion for forever 21
has a man's section
yes it does it's very nice they have
great graphic tees
that actually play around in fashion for
fun that's not their career but they get
a kick out of it yeah because they like
it
yeah i know but like like again remember
when we're having these conversations
we're talking about in general we're not
talking about like you want because why
does your your mind go to a specific
it's like you want to argue because
you're like oh this one person is an
exception to the
type because but a stereotype but
stereotypes
are backed up yeah like if they're
backed by data
and like gap in the window like ninety
percent it's like
like it's just like oh these ads just
have yeah straight up because their
target audience is us fashion is fully
rooted in women yeah yeah like
accessories right
exactly
because they know we're gonna spend that
was the only thing that we could do at
some point also and also i think that
this society
i think that the main thing is like
women
i don't know the statistic of how many
women are in the world how many men but
typically sex cell and women are
sexualized and so that's why they gear
to us like they know they're gonna buy
the stuff they know if they have if they
see a woman wearing something that
they're looking in this the women are
gonna be like
but are they sexualized for men or for
women if women make 80 percent of
consumer purposes
i think it's both
right
historically like let's look like
historically like
when
like when women wore corsets and they
were right little right things that you
think that like
right
that was because they were being brought
out into society to find a husband and
they were being sexualized so i feel
like that's also a point to be made like
they like when they have money it's like
oh well let's spend this on a dress but
again kathy but what is that like what
does that have to do with us today
because it's morphed into where it
trickles down to where we are but i just
i just i just i just believe in personal
responsibility like if you have bad
credit and you were born in 2020 like
that's your own fault no it's not it's
not that's true
there's a certain standard in society
for women of how we should be and we're
kind of like taught that not saying it's
verbal right that's pushed on us from uh
a teammate that i played volleyball with
her mother would not let her leave the
house without her nails done her hair
done and outfit and now i [ __ ] with
her i would be inside every day
but it's because she said no man is
going to want you
because you don't look the part
and but that's what it is
but if that's if that's the if that's
the case why are statistically the
majority of women overweight like if
that's the case if we were forced to
look a certain way right and that's that
that's the standard right that's the
like standard then like i don't and men
don't accept there's a lot of things
that go into
being overweight and if we go back to
what we talked about first about toxic
relationship and just like just stuff
that we go through emotionally
i think that
women i'm not saying that men don't go
through things emotionally but i feel
like women go through more emotionally
and have things right well we're more
more emotional yeah yeah and from that
the
the easiest thing to resort to is eating
and
just being
um well they changed our food to comfort
from the 50s yeah and so i think that
that may be the one the main thing
is just like it's just comfort finding
comfort and food food's always going to
comfort you no matter what
food and
i think that that is one thing not
canceling out like men don't go through
nothing and we all yeah yeah right but
it's just like that's one thing from
just what i've seen and what i've just
like so you think the majority of like
women being overweight is from emotional
like trauma
like let me can i just say yeah
like
growing up i was a stick like i was
stick then i was underweight i got put
on medication to gain weight because i
was unhealthily underweight right
and so i and when i was skinny it was
like all i wanted to do was have curves
like all i wanted was to have an ass
like that's all i could think about
i gained weight and then it's like the
the whole it's like the opposite right
and it's like i always felt like i was
trying to fit into a standard and it was
like never fit into i could never just
be because but it's also that's personal
on me because it's like well it's
interesting because i would look at you
like as the like you you're you're
stunning to be honest
like like that's what i'm saying but
it's interesting because like you you i
feel like you have to know you're hotter
than like most girls right but like are
you respectful as also being six three
right like growing up i was [ __ ]
bullied because i hit 6'3 when i was 13.
have you ever watched that one [ __ ]
those movies
oh those are the worst but like but like
i feel it like like literally it's funny
when you say like lebron james because
like when i was in middle school like
people be like oh kobe bryant lebron
james
watch all right say that in the tall
girl movie sasquatch and it's like that
has an effect on you and like people
would always make comments to me like i
was like 120 pounds and i was six three
like i was a [ __ ]
twin yeah like
it was
like i looked like a skeleton right and
then it's like all i wanted was this one
it was the curves yes you were
but you showed me pictures you were
curvy yeah up to a point yeah like i i
gained a lot of muscle right but then i
got on medication right gained a lot of
weight and then i was like
do you just want to be well do you do
you feel like that's society or that's
like an internal it's internal yeah
right
because society is either like you're
either a good curvy or you're
not there's no nasty thing but it's
interesting i'm skinny and there's bad
stuff but it's interesting because i
like to me it's all like like i think
women are meaner to women than men are
to be honest like girls are yeah
also the part where women are more
critical comes from their insecurities
oh yeah projection projection
women are very generous but that doesn't
yeah i know but it doesn't make it okay
absolutely not no
yeah it and what you meant by that like
women are meaner to women like most guys
aren't you know like men swipe on right
on like fifty percent of women like most
men aren't that big
most most no one's saying most men
aren't that picky like they're also
[Applause]
most men are attracted to like like a
lot of women like it's if you're getting
rejected by guys they're in a very small
percentage of men like 10 to 15 percent
of men even like they say um 20 of men
have access to 80 of the women so the
reason that we hate men is because we're
all effing the same ones yeah
like if you want a guy that's six foot
in the top fifteen percent amount
literally yeah yeah income
yeah yeah and so i'm saying the majority
of men aren't picky and so so women
because we're competing for those men
like they they tear at each other
each other because like from example
like
okay personally yeah never say there's
not a man that i've wanted that i
haven't got personally
there's been men that i've rejected that
have been like well i don't want your
fat ass anyways oh yeah oh yeah i'm
saying so it's like but like that [ __ ]
like sticks with you like you know yeah
i was like but you wanted me but now
you're calling me this why are you
feeling so hard for the cookies as soon
as i rejected this you suck yeah i try
to try to make it one at a time just so
like the i've just had comments that
they can't hear because there's too many
people talking
yeah yeah i get what you're saying okay
but like you know like
that [ __ ] like sticks with a person
right like like i remember there was one
time i was at cal berkeley and this guy
was hollering at me
and i was like please [ __ ] off like he
was such a little frat boy he's like
well i don't want your fat ass anyways
this was four years ago i was skinnier
than i was like 15 pounds lighter than
like i you know what i'm saying yeah
but like that [ __ ] like sticks with a
person like well he thought i was fat
like so it's like well the girls do like
i don't know girls kind of like are
worse almost behind each other's backs
well that's true it's just not to our
face we're more we're more behind the
back that part is fun yeah even in front
of their face girls are very spicy but
it's it's more sub like shady you know
men
men can't even see the looks that girls
give us at the bar and you know exactly
what looks like the the shade men can't
see it because um there's a biological
reasoning behind it but basically like
because women were like gatherers and
like we were more with the kids
biologically we pick up on other
people's emotions better so it's
i don't know but i do have
yeah go ahead go ahead a question what
and this might just be like a preference
or whatever but what is the cutoff
between because nowadays being big is
is not frowned upon at all it's worth
not worship but it's glorified but when
does it come a point where it's like
you're thick and then you're too big
like
i think it's your body shape to be
honest because you said the statistic is
a lot of women
i want to say well the average woman is
a hundred and
is five five 155 pounds which is like 20
pounds overweight something like that
yeah over average
no no i know i know i know yeah yeah but
like the average woman i i i don't know
the exact statistic off the top of my
head but she is overweight yeah yeah
like if you went to a doctor like he
would say yeah i mean
people can say whatever they want like
i'm a curvy like curvier girl like but
women like i know personally like i gain
a lot of weight in my hips like like um
some girls carry it better than others i
know like there's a like for
like
like genetically women carry more body
fat than men yes right
i tend to get gain weight in my hips and
like my birthing area right like that's
where i carry my weight
so that's all like it's they're like you
know what i'm you get what i'm saying so
it's like there's like
part yes like but it's all up to
preference like what are you into right
you know right so it's like what really
it like now
well but they're talking like
stick that i think kirby ways big ass
well i think the problem is when we look
at the guys that have all the options to
pick from they all seem to pick the
models
so that says something
and the guys and the guys and the guys
name one billionaire that's not married
to a model okay or even they're married
for like six seven years and then they
get a divorce and is that what your goal
is not all bill gates jeff bezos both of
their wives were married 20 plus years
they did get a divorce i'm sorry
bill gates wife is not that pretty and
same she wasn't she was when they both
well yeah because but that's that's
because they got them young men valley
white and white men tend to like thinner
women well they they got them young
before they were even rich
but we could we could take okay who is
kanye dating like we could use different
ones
like i think men with men a lot of the
rich men i can't even state names right
now sorry guys yeah
a lot of the rich men they go for models
the girls that actually want to get up
get a leg up in the industry get a leg
up in terms of their finances they're
actually working for money that's your
money motivated they go for rich men the
men want them because they know they can
gain that control over them and that's
why it works out i feel like it's not
about anything else well kim
kardashian's also if we're going to take
like a black billionaire like she's not
a black jew
no no no no no kanye is a black
billionaire or something she didn't she
was rich before kanye yeah no i know i
know but you said you you just said that
like those men pick women with nothing
going on basically so they can control
them more but i'm giving you an example
where that's not true
so i think connie had a huge impact over
kim i feel like with kim but she's
saying that you made this statement
where so so i'm saying if you're going
to make that statement like back it up
a lot of men a lot of yeah i can't even
think of names yeah
but they did go for women
that were below them hence in the model
industry like even a lot of right wife
porn stars because they know they want
the money they want the leg up they want
it etcetera right right makes it easier
well because men value different things
like women women like tend to date up
economically so if you if you're making
45 000 like you want a guy that makes
70. of course right but but men just
want a girl that's like fit feminine
friendly that's all they care about yeah
and the model model thing does it for
them yeah
for them that's actually
but i'm just trying to i'm just trying
to understand like the point you're
making
like a video recently about kanye's new
girl where she was like
yeah i guess i'm his muse you're like
a new girlfriend yeah they broke up
she literally would
her art
background was taking pictures of people
doing heroin while she was on heroin i
mean she's hot and she's
literally made her way
feminine friendly that's all that is all
men care about fit feminine friendly
actions like
that's weird to me
her art was literally people having dru
like we don't know we don't know
romanticizing
addiction is not weird we could agree
she was crazy like i'm
she was
like
do you like
control i feel like a lot of men are
raised up especially like because of
obvious generations
i don't think it's control i think it's
they want women that want to work with
them and aren't going to argue with them
every step of the way
to an extent no
women will be submissive to what they
want naturally sometimes as a man you
have to accept being challenged
sometimes yeah and i feel like because
men have a harder time stepping out of
their own perspective
they don't yeah they're not as accepting
when it comes to hearing a woman's
opinion on something especially if it's
not something that they're super
uh
knowledgeable about you know so
sometimes it is a control thing for men
i think but not always well i think i
think when you get to like i think when
you get to be like a one percent guy
right he's he's top five percent
whatever they they've run multi-million
dollar businesses
they probably know a lot of [ __ ] you
don't to be honest unless you're on that
same level but like
if i was dating a guy that's a
billionaire or a millionaire i would
trust his judge i'm sorry you don't have
to remember that that's the one percent
you know how many of us are really going
to touch the one percenter right
like that's a combination of you're
super you're very clearly
super intelligent but that's also luck
like not everyone is super intelligent
makes it so it's kind of like oh it's
not you're right it's partially luck but
i have not seen many people make a 20 30
year career without being somewhat smart
and subway driven right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
like you know it's like five minutes of
fame right like a year two years
okay wait um okay so the next super chat
so none of you would taking a spanking
from your significant other i'm not oh
you know like she's smacking she
literally gets pink or whatever he says
next one next one next one this show is
about to make pearl realize those chicks
from fresh and fit are the norm not the
outlier the wretchedness is internal
fellas period
sorry guys
nothing um other women's disrespectful
to us other women sorry i read all the
super chats um
other women's past don't justify your
present um thank you for the two dollars
super chat to um the 20 dkk i can waste
money too thank you please waste your
money here
here okay
ate my get get gabby a mike
give me a minute
hashtag
um okay so i'm gonna do
one last question to close out the show
would you rather date a guy that's flat
broke
but the hot like the finest man you've
ever seen in your life no
or super rich you never have to pay a
bill again
what no he's not toxic
but ugly yeah but ugly like he's shorter
than you
kind of overweight
date i know what he's married mary
you're with one guy
i have met the finest man that i will
ever meet and he was a thug and in and
out of jail and a drug dealer and he was
the sexiest man ever in my life and i
would never be with him because
what is he doing with his life nothing
what that drug money looking happy
medium what's that drug money looking
like not [ __ ] because he keeps going
into jail and he's gotta pay bail
you're right you're right
he's single an option right
d none of the above
literally like
i don't know that just that just sounds
like a mess i feel like
you know if i could hold my own and i'm
independent i'm probably going to go
with the attractive person
um
but like genuinely attractiveness for me
has to be your personality so physically
yeah if you
that's fine you could go you could go
with that yeah the personality is
included in the attraction good yeah
because
if we're just talking face like you
could be really fine but an [ __ ] so
like it's really not going to be worth
it to me if you broke and mean like pick
a struggle but
okay so you so you would pick hot you
would pick rich
you get to pick one hot
rich
okay
[Music]
and what about my kids
generational wealth i can trust that i
can hold it down like yeah but i don't
help him i listen
i come from a perspective where it's
like
i don't like i personally don't want my
kids to ever have to ask me like can i
do this and i don't want to say no like
can i go to this school can i do this no
like with the career that i'm going into
like probably like i'm gonna make 150
000 at the most like yeah personally so
it's like
if i'm really looking at like
the big picture
then i'm gonna go in the long run you
want to be able to help your kids that
makes sense because of my personal
experience yeah okay so so hot rich but
whatever i'm attracted to like no you're
you're attracted to the hot the kids
okay
so you
like it's not a thing what's your what's
your degree and i'm just curious
advance
does that does that how much does that
make
you you can make up to like 50k like
even more like a law it depends on what
part of the events you get into like you
can get into hosting a lot of things
marketing pr
so if you're at 50k though that's like
but that's the minimum like there's a
lot you can get up to you can get you
can like there's a lot of people that
make up to 100k like
a lot right right
you'd be cool with him being like a
stay-at-home husband to be honest i'm
like a career woman so yeah okay okay so
okay so hot hot rich
for me
if he has
something going for him because
essentially he doesn't not the hot one
if he doesn't honestly i'm gonna keep it
100 with you if he doesn't have nothing
going for him
i wouldn't choose either because i'm not
about to you would be by yourself yeah
i'm not about to be with someone that i
don't find attacks that's like the
highlight of this show no no you can you
can put it alone you just can't pick one
of them
yeah
i wouldn't want to just resort to
being with somebody because they have
money i'm gonna have my own i'm gonna
work hard for my own and have my own but
i don't want to resort to struggling
with somebody because i struggled my
whole life struggling with somebody that
because they're attractive well but the
the see for me like that would come at
the cost of not having kids and that
like i couldn't i could not i would i
think my like purpose on this earth is
to be a mother someday yeah so if i
didn't get to do like i
i would pick the hot one because i have
like the sexual chemistry of them right
no because i have family money so i
don't need it
she said i got many already not not not
now but some did so like for me like i
don't have family money but like i also
like i'm but also i'm italian i grow up
in a culture that's like
as many as you can yeah and i mean i'm
not gonna do that yeah like if i did i
would have probably three kids by now
yeah you're only 22. yeah but she said
by now
and then when do your parents start yeah
yeah so but like i don't know like i
don't have that to fall back on so if
we're going off of children like i want
to have at least three at least
like so that's why you'd pick the rich
guy because you'd have to afford it yeah
because like i also feel like i have a
sense like i'm such a motherly
personality and just in general like
i've i've always felt like part of my
purpose on this earth is to be a mom you
know what i'm gonna switch mine because
i just know if the guy was laying around
the house all the day i would not be
attracted to him no matter yeah yeah
he is i switched my answer i would take
him
you're still in the same
some [ __ ] that i'm gonna spot
oh my gosh
i'm gonna say like when it comes to the
person being ugly like if that includes
their personality i'm not gonna be able
to withstand that emotionally yep but if
they have a good personality and they're
ugly man i've been with some ugly
[ __ ] before so
you know it's not going to be that much
of a problem because no matter what like
as soon as i see you're a good person
you have a good heart yeah i'm always
going to be attracted to you yeah
exactly
exactly
okay well guys i apprec i think we had
over a hundred dollars worth of super
chats
[Music]
any all donations for the show can be
sent to my paypal hanna pearl davis at
gmail.com
or just pearly things on cash app um
let's raise the money for another set of
mics let's go people
and now everyone can give your closing
thoughts and then tell them where they
can find you if you want to put your
info out there
like your instagram or whatever go ahead
um
my closing thoughts uh i really enjoyed
this podcast and the conversations we
had because a lot of people don't really
have conversations like this or we're
not able to sit down in like a mixed
group to have different conversations
different ideas and talk about just
things like this um so i really enjoyed
it thank you for inviting me thank you
for coming
um but you can find me at instagram
it's your girl jess in between each
thing is a period and after
girl is an underscore so it's period
yeah period girl
underscore jess on instagram
um firstly thank you for having me on
this podcast but i think it's great like
for a lot of diverse women to come
together and actually discuss this topic
based on what they've gone through their
experiences from different backgrounds
different everything um i think it's
really great it shares a lot and it
relates to maybe a lot of people that
don't get to come forward and talk about
things and maybe they might not even
feel comfortable to cook with their
friends or they might feel judged et
cetera so i think it's really great um
but yeah follow me on instagram i have
an outfit page guys i'm quite crazy
um but yeah so it's wave culture but
wave and then
c-x-l-t-u-r-e
the link will be there
thanks
okay
well pearl you know
my bestie
the beautiful part about pearl and eyes
relationship is that we don't agree on
anything nothing
we agree on another
thing but the thing the the most
important part is we respect each
other's point of view even though we
don't agree on it yeah we even like the
hard conversations we always try to look
like a different way and if it's getting
a little too heated we always just say
you know what it doesn't matter because
it really doesn't like you know
i love you [ __ ]
thank you for having me but i already
been on the test
so no thanks for coming the audience
likes you you were requested last time
yes
yeah and let me know in the chat if you
guys want what topics you guys want us
to do next time and all super chats will
be read after chesca's thanks but thank
you for having me and i do appreciate
the conversations that we had tonight i
feel like are super important and
they're not ones that are had a lot even
though we may not have
delved into this the minutia
but it it's important yeah so thanks for
coming
um
well pearl the great thing about us is
that we also don't agree on
nothing and not only that we are not the
same whatsoever i'm black you white i'm
gay you straight
a lot a lot of different things play
volleyball together but
i'm always going to respect you as a
person because you would like to give a
different perspective yeah i equally
like to give different perspectives
we're both highly opinionated oh yeah i
like to take each other in what do you
think
why do you think i invited you i was
like nothing at all
you know i genuinely appreciate the
opportunity to come here and speak on
what i feel and hopefully i was able to
make it comedic enough i know nobody
spoke in that chat about me but that's
alright because i know i'm bad i know
i'm pretty harry
um unfortunately i don't have instagram
but i got a tick tock and it's
cheskedelic so c-h-e-s-k-a-d-e-l-i-c
but that's it thank you for having me
thank you so much for coming this was
such a fun first show
okay guys do not